BRET BAIER WERE COMING YOU
TONIGHT FROM FOX NEWS WORLD
HEADQUARTERS IN NEW YORK CITY.
THERE ARE SERIOUS QUESTIONS OVER
THE DEATH OF FINANCE JEFFREY AND
STEEN IN A HOLDING FACILITY IN A
STATE OVER THE WEEKEND THE
OFFICIAL EXPEDITION IS A SUICIDE
BUT THE CONSPIRACY THEORIES HAVE
BEEN RUNNING RABBITS.
AT THE AUTOPSY IS COMPLETE BUT
THE MEDICAL EXAMINER IS
REQUESTING MORE INFORMATION
BEFORE MAKING A FINAL
DETERMINATION.
WITH CORRESPONDENT BRIAN.
>> GOOD EVENING AS WE AWAIT TO
THE FINAL RESULTS COME OUT
TODAY, U.S. ATTORNEY GENERAL
WILLIAM BARR SLAMMED THE
METROPOLITAN CORRECTIONAL CENTER
IN MANHATTAN NEW YORK.
HE WAS FOUND DEAD AFTER AN
APPARENT SUICIDE SET UP.
>> I WAS APPALLED, INDEED THE
WHOLE DEPARTMENT WAS, AND
FRANKLY ANGRY.
TO LEARN OF THE M CC FAILURE TO
ADEQUATELY SECURE THIS PRISONER,
WE ARE NOW LEARNING OF A SERIES
OF IRREGULARITIES AT THIS
FACILITY.
>> FOX NEWS HAS LEARNED THAT HE
WAS NOT ON SUICIDE WATCH AT THE
TIME OF HIS DEATH.
DESPITE THE FACT THAT HE WAS
TEMPORARILY PUT ON SUICIDE WATCH
AFTER HE WAS REPORTEDLY FOUND IN
HIS CELL WITH BRUISING AROUND
HIS NECK TWO WEEKS AGO.
HE WAS ALSO NOT PHYSICALLY
CHECKED ON FOR SEVERAL HOURS
LEADING UP TO HIS DEATH EVEN
THOUGH HE SHOULD HAVE BEEN
CHECKED ON EVERY 30 MINUTES
ACCORDING TO MCC'S ARE NORMAL.
FAMILIAR WITH THE SITUATION
TELLS FOX NEWS, HE DID NOT HAVE
A CELLMATE AT THE TIME OF HIS
DEATH WHICH THE SOURCE
CHARACTERIZED AS UNUSUAL.
IF THE UNION REPRESENTING THE
GUARDS SAID ONE OF THE GUARDS
HAD WORKED 80 HOURS THAT WEEK,
THEY BLAMED THE BUREAU OF PRISON
AND THE TRIP ADMINISTRATION FOR
ALL TIME LOW STAFFING AT AN
EIGHT CC OVER THE LAST THREE
YEARS LEADING TO OVERWORKED
GUARDS.
"WE IN CPL 33 HAVE BEEN SOUNDING
THE ALARM FOR YEARS ABOUT THE
HIRING FREEZES, THE
UNDERFUNDING, AND HOW
UNDERSTAFFED OUR FACILITIES HAVE
BEEN NATIONWIDE ALL BECAUSE OF
THE POLICIES OF THIS
ADMINISTRATION.
"JACK DAWSON A FEDERAL PRISON
CONSULTANT SAYS INMATES ARE
RARELY LEFT ON SUICIDE WATCH FOR
MORE THAN A WEEK.
>> YOU CANNOT STOP AN INMATE
FROM COMMITTING SUICIDE.
THERE'S NO POLICY IN THE WORLD
THAT'S GOING TO PREVENT THAT
WHATSOEVER.
>> THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
CONDUCTED THEIR INVESTIGATION
CONSPIRACY THEORISTS HAVE
FLOODED THE INTERNET INCLUDING
ONE UNFUNDED THEORY BY
PRESIDENT DONALD TRUMP OR THE
WEEKEND THAT BLAMED THE CLINTONS
FOR HIS DEATH.
KELLYANNE CONWAY DEFENDED THE
TWEETS ON FOX NEWS SUNDAY.
>> THE PRESIDENT WANTS
EVERYTHING TO BE INVESTIGATED.
>> GENERAL ALSO SAID THAT HIS
CRIMINAL CASE WILL CONTINUE
AGAINST ANYONE WHO IS COMPLACENT
WITH HIS ALLEGED SEX TRAFFICKING
NETWORKS SAYING "I NEED
CONSPIRATORS SHOULD NOT REST